good morning belief nation today we're
going to talk about how you can improve
your mindset the key to success is not
simply effort or focus or resilience but
it is the growth mindset that creates
them the my city self is critical
research shows that when we directly try
to build grit or persistence it is not
nearly as effective as addressing the
mindset that underlies them how many of
us think of ourselves as not math people
or creative or sociable or athletic or
conversely that the word Naturals if
we're to fulfill our potential we have
to start thinking differently we have to
realize that our we're not chained to
our current capabilities neuroscience
shows that the brain is very malleable
and we can change our own ability to
think and to perform in fact many of the
most accomplished people of our era were
thought of by experts to have no future
people like Charles Darwin Lucille Ball
Marcel Proust and many others but they
along with all great achievers from
Mozart to Einstein built their abilities
number one is to recognize when you're
not being positive and recognize what's
happening on a vibrational level Esther
Hicks talks about this right in Abraham
she talks about how when were in a
negative cycle our vibration level comes
down and we're operating on a different
disk you're going to start attracting
things into your life that match that
frequency almost like an antenna so
other negative situations other negative
circumstances and I've seen this happen
so much in my life like this continuum
this vicious cycle when I'm in a
negative state that constantly brings up
more negative stuff so the earlier you
figure out that you are in this position
you can transcend it even if it's really
hard to do like you're searching for
everything in the depths of your soul on
the bottom of your heart to really pull
some goodness out of what's happening in
your life in this moment it's going to
have a cascade effect I promise you my
friend where maybe it's one thing you're
grateful for and the leads to another
thing it's something bigger
right something brighter opens you up
your mindset starts to the peak a little
bit and then something bigger on top of
that and then sure enough you're
operating on a different disc and as you
go up the ladder as she talks about in
your book called the vortex you start to
accumulate more positivity and you live
in this state of goodness where people
place in places things circumstances
come in in a continual basis to you
because you're operating like this so
it's recognizing the difference get out
of the negative zone as quick as
possible something negative happens
brush it off recognize you're not the
experience you're not the emotion from
it and move away from it as soon as
possible starting when I was 17 I
started doing incantations not
affirmations affirmation you go home
happy I'm happy I'm happy I'm happy I'm
heavy what's the problem you haven't
changed your what your what physiology
if you don't change your physiology you
won't get anything so an incantation is
you only you speak it but you embody
what you're saying with all the
intensity you can and you do it with
enough repetitions that it sticks in
your head like it's a small world now
the conversation your head is always the
same it gives you what you want so use
your body and your voice so 17 years ago
I started doing things I was working for
Jim Rohn this
speaker I was 17 years old I had long
hair minestrone soup acne on my face now
it's trying to call on Bear Stearns type
of people and convince them why they
should go to this man seminar be more
successful I was driving a 1968
Volkswagen that I turned at $40 a week
as a janitor the only way I did it was
park far from the building and then go
in and I love people I believe what I
put myself in state and I was able to
influence people that were far more
successful I was at the time I will do
something that I still do backstage and
I've done for 23 years because I don't
hope I'm gonna be in a good state I
demand it so I do an incantation using
my whole body I now command my
subconscious mind to directly in helping
as many people's possible life today to
better their lives by giving me the
strength the emotion the persuasion the
humor the brevity whatever it takes to
show these people and get these people
to change their lives now I would do
that literally driving in my Volkswagen
to a meeting in LA on the freeway for 40
minutes people look I'm screaming to top
my lungs they're going I know he's a
serial killer I know he is but by the
time I entered that room when two people
meet if there's a rapport the person
who's most certain will always influence
the other person and I was Posey certain
and they were trying to get revved up to
certainty do you agree with this yes or
no I do another one because I was poor I
changed my mindset I kept doing things
but I never got beyond it I'd say gods
wealth is circulating in my life as
wealth flows to me an avalanche is of
abundance all my needs desires and goals
are met instantaneously by infinite
intelligence for I'm one with God and
God is everything and I would imagine
the abundance of my life and I would
feel so grateful and I learn I went for
making thirty eight thousand dollars a
year to make a million dollars a year
and one year but successful people do
what failures won't involve me honest
people often who have negative recurring
thoughts and feelings in their life the
reason those keep coming up all the time
is because they they've at some point in
their life or continually are giving
those thoughts the negative ones more
attention than necessarily any other
thoughts in other words the relative
weight that they give those thoughts is
quite high and they give a lot of
importance in that ilysm those thoughts
are very
to me right now and they're there
durational elast over a period of time
they keep thinking about those thoughts
thinking about those think about those
thoughts and it's all that repetition
that seals it in the back of their head
and now their head says oh this is an
easy thing I know this one and it pulls
it forward so that simple repetition
because they made it important and they
thought about it a lot it keeps coming
up for them over and over and over again
so there's two negative there's a good
negative thing about that a positive
thing the negative is if you keep
obsessing about negative things your
mind will be automatic and conditioned
to bring it up more and more and more
often without your control just
automatically the positive aspect is we
can use that same skill set and that
same rule to apply positive thoughts
into our own life we can give positive
thinking positive questions positive
approaches to life a lot of importance
in our life and a lot of focus and focus
on them and give a lot of duration to
them over a period of time and they get
sealed in the brain as well and now the
brain says well that's easy
automatically thinks about it so for me
personally I've done this so much in my
life that I just have I automatically
think about the best possible outcomes
and almost everything I do I used to
think about the negative outcomes I
thought that's not supporting me so how
did I do that
well leveraging our W idea it helped and
let me break it down for you little bit
about how you can do this because the
first thing you have to do in order to
improve your mind is take total control
of your attention and notice where are
your thoughts right now at a very
continual basis you have to think where
are my thoughts right now are they
supporting me or are they automatically
coming up negative and self protective
in ways that are not advancing my life
just to be aware to be conscious of
what's going on in your body in your
sense of feeling and emotion and the
sense of the thoughts you're actually
having just start paying attention you
know for a lot of people because they've
never done this before and it's hard to
remind them to do it it's like simple
here's what I want you to do just start
paying attention to your thoughts
anytime you're in line anytime you're in
line from now on if you're in line at
Starbucks just say I'm in line at
Starbucks spread and said think about my
thoughts what are my thoughts saying
right now just checking in you're in
line and trap
waiting for the next car just sitting
like what are my thoughts right now and
just notice what you've been thinking
about the more did we notice what we've
been thinking about the more we can
interrupt what we've been thinking about
see if we just allow that feeling to
keep coming up and you don't pay
attention to it it our life can be very
frazzled and very highly anxious but
once you say what's my mind on right now
and we redirect it that is where
personal power comes from first
awareness right and understanding and
the consciousness of what's going on but
then the ability now to be self-directed
to choose what we want to focus on so
first we're attentive to it and then
redirect it if it's negative it's not
supporting you redirected how do you
redirect it first of all most you just
say what would be the opposite of this
negative thing that you think about the
positive thing and you focus on that and
you repeat it to yourself for many
people that might include closing their
eyes just visualizing a more positive
outcome thinking about the more positive
outcome thinking about more positive
outcome thinking about the more positive
outcome focusing on with their eyes
closed and that visualization of a more
positive outcome of how things could
turn out well or how would the situation
could be better or even just what are
the next steps I should take visualizing
that and assigning a high amount of
importance and duration to it meaning
making that thing important to us by
making it how do you make something
important you give it a sensation you
feel that thing you sense it you sense
what your next step would be you sense
how and feel at the outcome would be
better how would it feel emotionally
psychologically spiritually for that
thing to allow it to have a lot of
emotion to it pay attention to your eyes
closed you see that thing you feel it
you sense a different step you know what
you're going to do you pay attention to
it and you keep focusing on that so
we're a period of merits keep focusing
and keep focusing focusing when your
mind automatically wants to go back to
easy which might be negative you're you
go no no no I don't want it I don't want
I'm not into easy right now I'm into
conditioning my mind focus focus focus
focus give attention duration and
sensation to attention duration
sensation attention duration sensation
visualization visualization
it's repetition of that positive
alternative to a negative impulsed that
comes up that gives us personal power
let me say it again it's that attention
to that positive alternative over
attention to repeating that negative
impulse or thought that gives us
personal power you can get a lot of
little tricks out there that will help
you to think positively to be more
optimistic but I think if you want to
really cultivate positive thinking
within yourself you have to start to
take on this idea that there's something
deeper going on in life and that it's
not quite so simple to figure out
exactly what it is if you think about
all the really challenging they're
really hard times you've had in your own
life all the really unfortunate times
the ones that we would obviously label
as unfortunate and then you trace back
the ripple effects from that through the
rest of your life and into the present
you trace that back and you take a look
a lot of times what you find is you find
your greatest gifts there you find your
greatest strengths there you have you
find your greatest growth there you find
your biggest lessons in life you find
your biggest successes stemming from
that being born from it so those really
challenging times a lot of times they
are the seeds for our ultimate success
so don't be so quick to dismiss those as
being bad and that is what you're doing
most of the time most of the time when
you're thinking negatively when you're
worrying when you're afraid when you're
really angry or you're feeling hurt I
mean it feels real and it is real I mean
it hurts it gets you mad
it gets you anxious but if you start to
become more of a positive thinker you
really start to buy into this deeper
philosophy you start to realize that
that's not necessary and then in fact a
lot of times you're worrying about the
things that are really good for you the
things that are really going to make you
grow the things that are really going to
make you
successful there's something to this
idea that there can be no problem that
is not an opportunity in your life and I
think this is what the core of positive
thinking is is understanding that every
problem every challenge that you have is
ultimately an opportunity and this is
not just some wishful thinking this has
not said lightly this is something that
takes some study this has takes some
study and some contemplation to
understand it takes wisdom to really
understand this you have to have some
life experience to start to see the
truth of this the depth of it because
there's like a surface level
understanding and then how much deeper
layer of understanding that's why you
have to kind of go back and look at your
own history just try to prove it to
yourself to prove yourself of this is
true because right now I tell you this
but you're probably saying yes this
sounds nice and sure it could probably
work for many problems in my life I can
see that somehow I'm catastrophizing
them exaggerating them a lot of times
they don't come true but you know
there's just this one problem I've got
right now I've got this one problem
that's just pure hell it's pure hell
it's pure evil there's no possible way
that this problem I've got right here
there's no possible way that this could
have any opportunity in it there's no
opportunity here there's no lesson to be
learned here
there's nothing pot this is just pure
negative if I could remove it from my
life my life would be happy I would be
better I just know it well that's
exactly what I'm trying to tell you is
that that's not positive thinking and I
mean I understand where you're coming
from a lot of times I get triggered like
that too and I was especially like that
a lot in the past and I'm still a bit
like that today but you can understand
that this is the mode of thinking that
you've been coming from for most of your
life and that that mode of thinking has
gotten you to where you are right now in
your life so that's gotten you to where
you are
but that's only gotten you to where you
are and I'm willing to bet that you can
do better than where you are right now
and if you really want to go to that
next level
then what you have to do is you have to
start to think in a different way
sometimes if I start thinking in a
radically different way a way that seems
uncomfortable a way that seems wishful
thinking at first a way that seems
unrealistic that seems idealistic that
seems fantastical yet there is something
to this idea that nothing can happen to
you that is not positive we conducted
another experiment this time we told
participants about the current governor
of an important state who is running for
re-election against his opponent we
again had two groups of participants and
we described the current governors track
record to them in one of two ways we
said that when the current governor took
office statewide budget cuts were
expected to affect about 10,000 jobs and
then half the participants read that
under the current governor's leadership
forty percent of these jobs had been
saved and they like the current governor
they think he's doing a great job the
rest of the participants read that under
the current governor's leadership 60% of
these jobs had been lost and they don't
like the current governor they think
he's doing a terrible job but then once
more we added a twist for participants
in the first group we reframed the
information in terms of losses and now
they didn't like the current governor
anymore and for participants in the
second group we reframed the information
in terms of games but just like in the
first study this didn't seem to matter
people in this group still didn't like
the current governor so notice what this
means
once the loss frame gets in there it
sticks people can't go back to thinking
about jobs saved once they've thought
about jobs lost so in both of these
scenarios actually the current governor
gets out stood in favor of his opponent
well at this point we were getting
curious why does this happen could it be
that it's actually mentally harder for
people to convert from losses to gains
than it is for them to go from gains to
losses so we conducted a third study to
test how easily people could convert
from one frame to another the
time we told participants imagine
there's been an outbreak of an unusual
disease and 600 lives are at stake
and we asked participants in one group
if 100 lives are saved how many will be
lost and we asked participants in the
other group if 100 lives are lost how
many will be saved so everyone just has
to calculate 600 minus 100 and come up
with the answer of 500 but whereas
people in one group have to convert from
gains to losses in order to do that
people in the second group have to
convert from losses to gains we timed
how long it took them to solve this
simple math problem and what we found
was that when people had to convert from
gains to losses they could solve the
problem quite quickly took them about
seven seconds on average but when they
had to convert from losses to gains
well now it took them far longer almost
11 seconds so this suggests that once we
think about something as a loss that way
of thinking about it tends to stick in
our heads and to resist our attempts to
change it would I take away from this
research and from related research is
that our view of the world has a
fundamental tendency to tilt toward the
negative it's pretty easy to go from
good to bad but far harder to shift from
bad to good we literally have to work
harder to see the upside of things and
this matter so think about the economy
here's economic well-being from 2007 to
2010 and you can see it tanked just like
we all remember and then by late 2010 it
had recovered by most objective measures
but here's consumer confidence over the
same time period you can see it tanks
right along with the economy but then it
seems to get stuck
instead of rebounding with the economy
itself consumers seem to be
psychologically stuck back there in the
recession so oddly then it may take more
effort to change our minds about how the
economy is doing than to change the
economy itself on a more personal level
with this research means to me is that
you have to work to see the upside
literally this takes work this
takes effort and you can practice this
you can train your mind to do this
better there is research out of UC Davis
showing that just writing for a few
minutes each day about things that
you're grateful for can dramatically
boost your happiness and well-being and
even your health
we can also rehearse good news and share
it with others we tend to think right
that misery loves company that venting
will help get rid of our negative
emotions that will feel better if we
just talk about how terrible our day was
and so we talk and we talk and we talk
about the boss who's driving us crazy
and the friend who never called us back
and the meeting at work where every
little thing that could go wrong did but
we forget to talk about the good stuff
and yet that's exactly where our minds
need the most practice so my husband who
has this disconcerting habit of
listening to what I say other people
should do and then pointing out that
technically speaking I'm a person too
has has taken to listening to me
for about two minutes on days when I
come home all grumpy and complaining
about everything and he listens and he
says okay but what happened today that
was good and so I tell him about the
student who came up to me after class
with this really interesting insightful
question and I tell him about the friend
who emailed me out of the blue this
morning just to say hello and somewhere
in the telling I start to smile and I
start to think that maybe my day was
pretty decent after all I think we can
also work in our communities to focus on
the upside we can be more aware that bad
tends to stick one mean comment can
stick with somebody all day all week
even and that tends to propagate itself
right somebody snaps at you and you snap
back and you snap at the next guy too
but what if the next time somebody
snapped at you you forgave them what if
the next time you had a really grumpy
waitress you left her an extra-large tip
our minds may be built to look for
negative information and to hold on to
it but we can also retrain our minds if
we put some effort into it and start to
see that the glass may be a little more
full than we initially thought for me
improving my mindset comes down to two
things the first is about having goals
that are inspiring feeling like you're
doing work that is exciting that you're
challenging yourself that you're growing
it's really hard at least for me to have
a positive mindset when I'm working on
things that I'm not excited about if I'm
just working on stuff that is boring and
unexcited I'm not going to wake up super
exciting ready to do it or if I feel
like there's a challenge that I'm going
after that I'm pushing myself that I'm
learning something new then it's a lot
easier for me to have that positive
mindset so I think as entrepreneurs we
always need to have growth goals that
we're working toward to keep us
motivated and excited the second thing
for me is about the environment and once
you have that big goal that you're
shooting towards creating that
environment to keep you motivated and
keep the mindset positive I find for me
it's a it's almost a daily refresh so I
need to start my day and whatever
mindset I had yesterday poof gone I need
to start over today and so having habits
and routine and a schedule in the
morning that sets you up for success
that you're surrounding yourself with
people that make you want to go off and
do something bigger that you're around
resources and ideas that stretch you to
have a more positive mindset that's why
I created the entresto series so you
start every day with something to
hopefully boost you out of your comfort
zone to go and do something greater
those two things I find super helpful so
having goals that are that make you
excited and have an environment to
support you doing something great do
that and you'll have a amazing mind set
to continue to grow
so thank you so much for watching this
episode of believe life we made this
topic because bass drop beats ask me too
so if there's a topic you want us to
cover in the next addition to believe
life leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of the clips that you saw
today had the biggest impact on you on
why leave it in the comments and I'll
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe I don't see you soon
the first thing if you're having
negative recurring thoughts and feelings
that are coming up those are really
they're just they're easy and here's
what I mean by that you know we have two
systems of thought psychologists like to
say now we have the system one theories
in which the system one is your
automatic just unconscious immediate
thoughts and impulses that come up from
your body that usually your brain is
just saying hey dude we've thought
through this before
or hey dude we're trying to protect you
so it's running at a very baseline easy
energetic level your brain loves to
optimize itself it doesn't like to have
to do a whole lot of thinking it just
likes to say what do we already know how
can we apply it to the situation so if
you had fears in the past and similar
situations here your body just generates
those fears and says hey man run away
again
if you had the challenges in the past
and you want to protect yourself your
brain just says hey protect yourself
right now we're worried about this but
sometimes those are not helpful thoughts
they're automatic but they're not
actually helpful it's just your brain
saying this is the easiest route we know
and part of becoming a more mature
conscious enlightened person is to
better take control of our system -
which is our sort of conscious dashboard
on our mind our ability to more directly
work control generate and create our own
thoughts and behaviors in the moment not
relying too much on just the things that
come up for us now of course we're
always going to most of our lives is
very system one driven very unconscious
automatic we just going through the
motions but the people who achieve the
peak amounts of success the highest
performers in the world have said you
know what I need to discipline my mind
to support me even when it comes up with
an automatic immediate thoughts I want
those to be positive and buoyant and
confident and strong something that
leads me to healthy decisions for my
life not just things that protect me and
so I think that we have to learn how to
do that a positive mental attitude can
clear away all obstacles which stand
between you and you
major purpose in life because of the
importance of the subject of our visit
I shall not only tell you that a
positive mental attitude it's the entire
list of the 12 great riches in life but
I am going to give you explicit
instructions as to what you must do to
keep your mind positive in all the
success books I have written I have
never suggested to my readers what they
should do without clearly telling them
how to do it
are you ready if you are ready this
visit may bring the most important
change in your life you have ever
experienced one learn to adjust yourself
to other people's state of mind and
difficulties so as to get along
peacefully with them and to refrain from
taking notice of trivial circumstances
in your relations with other people by
refusing to allow them to become
controversial incidents great people
always avoid small incidents of
controversy when possible to establish
for yourself a definite fixed system of
conditioning your mind at the beginning
of each day so you will keep it positive
under all circumstances 3 learn the art
of selling yourself to other people by
indirection
such as asking leading questions which
will bring out the sort of reactions
from others which you desire and do not
permit yourself to be drawn into
argument over unimportant subjects 4
adopt the habit of having a good heart
and laugh every time you become
irritated or angry and it will help you
if you begin each day with one minute of
hearty laughing this will change the
chemistry of your brain and start you
out with a positive mental attitude
however you had better get out of sight
when you take your laughing exercise 5
start each day with an expression of
gratitude for all the adversities
defeats failures you have experienced in
the past and a search for the seed of an
equivalent benefit these have yielded
you through the passing of time then
give thanks for the blessings
things you expect to receive during the
day six learn to concentrate your
attention on the can-do portion of all
of your problems and desires and start
action where you stand in carrying out
this portion no matter what may be your
problem or your desire there is always
something you can do right now that will
help you find out what this something is
and do it seven learn to transmute all
unpleasant circumstances into immediate
action which calls for a positive mental
attitude and make this a fixed habit for
example when you are angry switch your
mind to some sort of action in
connection with your hobby or your major
purpose in life and to keep it busy with
that subject for five minutes
eight recognize that every circumstance
which influences your life whether it is
a pleasant or unpleasant circumstance is
wrist or your mill of life and so use it
to make it pay you dividends in one form
or another
remembering meanwhile that your strength
grows out of your struggles follow this
instruction and you will soon learn that
there is no such thing as an
unprofitable experience 9 look upon your
life as a continuous process of
Education of learning from all your
experiences good and bad and to be
always on the alert for gains of wisdom
which come to you a little at a time in
both your pleasant and unpleasant
experiences 10 make the world over to
fit your own pattern if you choose but
begin with yourself in some sort of
self-improvement which will make you
more open-minded patient and generous in
your relations with others 11 express
gratitude twice daily for your
recognition of the fact that you have
been given complete control over your
own mind and ask for guidance in order
that you may use this profound gift
wisely in all your thoughts and acts 12
go out of your way daily to comment
on the good qualities of those with whom
you live and work but do not mention
their negative qualities then observers
benefit to yourself how quickly others
will begin to concentrate on your good
qualities remember I'm still talking
about how to keep your mind positive and
thirteen accept all criticism of
yourself as an occasion for
self-examination to determine how much
of it is justified and you will be sure
to make startling discoveries about
yourself which will help you to the
remainder of your lives
14 do not accept from life or anyone
else anything you do not desire and
remember that Mahatma Gandhi proved
himself to be more powerful than the
great British military forces by this
simple method of passive resistance 15
remember always that there are two kinds
of circumstances which cause you to
worry those you can do something about
and those you can do nothing about
nothing that is except to use passive
resistance and refuse to permit them to
worry you 16 keep your mind eternally
engaged in thinking of that which you
desire most your major purpose in life
so no time will be left for you to waste
on thinking of that which you do not
want and let me digress here while I
tell you we are now rubbing elbows with
the great master key of success this
very moment and 17 if you should ever be
so unfortunate as to feel sorry for
yourself look around until you find
someone who is worse off than yourself
and start where you stand or give him
he'll make this procedure a habit and
you will witness one of the great
miracles of life because that which you
do - or for another you do - or for
yourselves and 18 choose some person
whom you consider to be the sort of
person you would like to be then go to
work and emulate that person
every way possible great people have
always been hero worshipers but they
picked the right sort of people to
annihilate 19 cultivate your tone of
voice so that your words have a pleasing
musical sound and remember that the
sound of your voice is an open window
through which other people look into
your very soul it will be a profitable
investment if you will get a tape
recording machine and record samples of
your voice daily while you practice the
art of expressing yourself through a
friendly sounding voice if you are
engaged in selling this practice will
quickly pay off in military dividends 20
last but by no means the least write out
this sentence and paste it in a
prominent place where you work and on a
mirror where you see yourself in your
home whatever the mind can conceive and
believe the mind can achieve remember
also that you're the only person who can
provide you with a positive mental
attitude what are you going to do about
it on your answer to this question rest
your entire future